-Welcome back. We're here with
Colin Jost and Michael Che.
Jost, you guys both
made some sketch appearances,
which doesn't happen
that often on the show.
You were in
a Kool-Aid commercial, which --
There you go.
-Yes.
Michael Che cast me
in his Kool-Aid commercial.
-Yeah.
-We're basically only
put in sketches --
at least me --
when they say,
"We have no cast available."
-Right.
-The shoot's at 5:00 a.m.
Only Jost will come.
-You're cheaper
than hiring an extra?
-Yes.
I'm just like an extra.
-Che, you have done some
cast work on the show, as well.
There you are.
You're the Scarecrow right here.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-In a version of "The Wiz"
with, of course, Ryan Gosling.
Who else would be in "The Wiz"?
But it was -- the best burn on
Che is that he's a Scarecrow.
You cannot tell it's him,
and he spent like six hours
in makeup all the time
to get into it.
-The best is everyone
calls me "Black Scarecrow,"
and I'm like,
"It's just Scarecrow."
[ Laughter ]
-You were
in a Scientology ad, Jost?
-I was -- Scientol -- yes.
-You're very believable.
-I know.
That's really one of my finest.
-You played
Lester Holt on the show.
-Yes.
-Which was wonderful,
but then there was an article.
The title of the article is
"Watching History:
Find out all
the familiar TV faces
covering the final lap
of the 2016 election."
And so this was
an actual newspaper article,
or online newspaper article.
Anderson Cooper, Megyn Kelly,
and then you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Your Lester Holt was so good...
-Yeah, shout-out
to the makeup department.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is very -- you did --
This was a bit you did
on "Update"
where you played Gretchen.
-You went undercover
as a white girl named Gretchen.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I went undercover as a liberal
white woman named Gretchen,
and I didn't use makeup,
but it was still believable.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then you guys had an idea,
like a second round of this.
-Yeah.
-Now, so the idea --
Explain how
it was supposed to work.
-The last show,
we had an idea that got cut --
that was -- I said to Che,
"Well, you went undercover
as a white woman named Gretchen
to try to figure out
that situation."
And I had been reading all this
terrible stuff about R. Kelly,
so I thought
maybe I could go undercover
as a black teenage girl
to try to entrap R. Kelly.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
Yes, exactly, boos.
Thank you.
-That's, uh --
You know what?
That sounds like
a man of Manny Manimals.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, the idea was, I knew
it was the worst idea ever.
-Right.
So you did not shoot it.
-No, the idea
was Che would stop me
and point out
how awful of an idea that was,
and I would say, "Really?
It doesn't go both ways?"
And he was like,
"Absolutely not."
And I was like,
"Oh, yeah, that makes sense."
-Gotcha.
-And then it said,
"The more you know."
Like the little --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ "The more you --" ♪♪
Yeah, you could tell.
We're glad it was cut.
I think that seems fair.
The audience approves.
-I begged him not to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-How often -- one of my favorite
things you guys do,
that you did
for the Christmas show, right?
Where you make each other
read jokes
that the other one
has not seen first.
-Right.
-You seem to have a lot of fun
putting each other
in uncomfortable situations.
-Oh, yeah.
-He made --
The slug came up for one
he made me tell,
which was
National Rosa Parks Day came up,
when the joke he made me tell
without having read it,
and my family said they were all
-- like, lost their breath.
[ Laughter ]
And they were like,
"We're watching
our son's end right now."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you remember the joke?
-No, I don't.
-That's for the best.
James McAvoy this week.
He should be fantastic.
-Oh, my God, yeah.
He's great.
He already plays 12 different
characters in "Split."
-Yeah. That's basically
a whole episode.
-There you go.
We're good.
We'll just do each of those.
He's great.
He was on your show.
-He's incredibly charming,
great actor, so I'm really
looking forward to that.
Gentlemen, it's always so great
to have you here.
Warm up.
We got you a space heater
back in your dressing room.
[ Laughter ]
Colin Jost and Michael Che,
everybody.